this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
thanks for joining us here at 11 i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis we
start with a developing story up in the
northwest valley police say someone shot
at a burglars in their apartment one of
them a juvenile all right so let's get
straight out to victoria saha near
rancho and decatur for an update for us
victoria
brian and denise good evening we are on
madre mason here you can see much of the
block is
blocked off by police and their crime
tape i don't know if you can see there
but you have an investigator taking
pictures still and with her flashlight
trying to find any clues here's what we
do know
officers responded to the scene just
after 7 p.m they say a resident came
home to find their apartment being
burglarized and start shooting up the
burglars we do know that one of those
burglars is a minor and was hit but was
taken to the hospital with
non-life-threatening injuries police are
still trying to continue their
investigation into the shooting and
justify that shooting as well please
stay with us for any updates reporting
live tonight victoria zaha live local
now